[Applaudissements]
merci voilà c'est bon c'est bon
ouais ouais c'est ça foutrait de ma
gueule on y va attention première
chanteuse
la musique va partir apparemment su
professionnelle puisqu'elle demande la
musique tout de suite
[Musique]
le one only you i'm à la mlb
et table et je voudrais pouvoir un jour
enfin te le dire
[Applaudissements]
là on la prépare la peau
olé
[Applaudissements]
ces jeux voice et mettre la musique de
nouvelle star c'est le shaq choucas j'y
étais c'était très beau mais c'était
juste un ton en dessous même ce qui est
une performance incroyable parce que
chanter aussi faux aaa temps et vous les
voulez voir qui vous retournez attention
deuxième deuxième chanteur ou chanteuse
qui vient nous rejoindre
excusez-moi fait toujours partie des
missions elle attendait alors elle va
chanter a capella elle veut surtout à
capella ouais bah oury bah fallait le
dire el botcho allait elle chante on
attrape et là c'est pas un crack
hululements des sétois le jacquot plongé
dans un bistrot des dégoûtés des deux
mois j'étais par oral et gégé laver les
carreaux piero ne faisait rien on sait
ce que je vois ce que j'aimerais
reprendre juste après c'est pas la
chance aux chansons aux siens
[Applaudissements]
je vois pas ce que c'est c'est
surréaliste
moi je n'ai pas écrit mais non alors à
la baule persan micro fin micro bon non
mais après tu comprends les castings
pourquoi après c'est la gueule allez on
y va on s'était fait les poches pour se
payer leur tour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention troisième chanteurs ou
chanteuses attention c'est participent
mais larry taylor une fois alors là on
va voir s'ils vont se retourner
ici pas attention c'est parti on y va on
s'en fuir
[Musique]
ouah
mr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'accord la méthode soir j raconter
n'importe quoi le 30 mai sont pas les
programmes you say me plais the beast ça
veut dire je suis participer à
l'émission de tf1 ce basque et la ba
voila voulait on voit que c'était
professionnels
[Applaudissements]
bravo je voudrais remercier andré
manoukian lots dessins cachés ils valent
en direct ce soir chéri vous avez vous
préparé on vous regardera ce soir promis
et vous savez je suis pas le double
échec vraiment je faisais mon ces voix
là joseph c'est l'émission
[Applaudissements]
sacré michael o'neill est au repos ce
soir à 21 heures
[Applaudissements]